so what now i reckon you want a kiss
kissing would be nice yes
[Music]
it was a groundbreaking moment for
disney princesses
she is someone who is determined and
forward moving
and now the movie's getting the theme
park treatment
here's the story of how the princess and
the frog made cinema
[Music]
the history disney company has built an
iconic library of animated films
i have all the dvds of the disney vaults
but after nearly a century of disney
princesses
there was a problem there wasn't a black
princess
while the studio started to feature more
diverse characters in the 90s
not to mention the countless cats dogs
mice elephants talking cars
and whatever the hell stitch was
by 2007 the company had yet to introduce
audiences to a black princess a much
needed character when it comes to
representation
but it was that year 2007 when
everything changed
that's when disney revealed plans for a
brand new animated movie
featuring the studio's first black
princess tiana
the frog princess has turned into a bit
of a princess finally
the story would put a twist on the
classic brothers grimm fairy tale
focusing on an aspiring chef and
entrepreneur in 1920s new orleans
[Music]
upon its debut in 2009 the voice of
tiana
anika noni rose immediately witnessed
the impact the princess was having on
audiences
around the world princess
can i tell you i have two little boys
and i took him to the movie my wife went
because she was like i gotta i've been
waiting for a black princess forever
but what kind of feedback are you
getting i've gotten amazing feedback and
and wonderfully it hasn't just been
in our community it's been sort of
widespread people that have been waiting
and excited about this and really
moved by her because she is a princess
that has a mind of her own and she is
someone who is
determined and forward-moving oh
it serves me right for wishing on stars
the only way to get what you want in
this world is through hard work
it's really wonderful it's something i
wanted to do my whole life to be a
disney voice
and i didn't you know you don't know how
much it means to people until
you can imagine because you know what it
means to you but until you see those
children come up to you
big-eyed and their parents teary it's
it's really quite an amazing thing
the dream continued for anika in 2018
when she got to bring tiana back to the
big screen
along with a slew of other disney
princesses and ralph breaks the internet
well i guess it's back to the gowns
girls this group of people
has been wanting that type of thing to
happen i think for ages so it was like
the ultimate surprise
and and really thrilling to be out there
with all of these princesses who have
had their
moment singularly but here we are
together like it's sort of amazing
in the decades since its debut the
princess in the frog is seen as a
pivotal moment of representation for
disney
and one that perhaps paved the way for
the studio's recent casting
announcements
such as hallie bailey becoming ariel in
the upcoming live-action version of the
little mermaid
you posted about hallie yeah oh my god
how cool is that
when you hear her voice like everything
about it and i feel like if anything
i'm excited for a group of young people
to grow up with her as ariel i know what
it did for me when i saw princess and
the frog
now the princess and the frog's legacy
is only getting bigger
putting down roots at the house of mouse
disney announcing some changes coming to
its popular attraction splash mountain
after 30 years as a beloved attraction
in disney parks the company recently
unveiled its plans for a makeover that
will retheme splash mountain
with characters from the princess and
the frog the brare rabbit themed ride
has been controversial for a long time
it's based off characters and songs from
song of the south
a disney film with racist themes it's a
great moment to do better this means for
the second time
in just over a decade princess tiana is
bringing
long overdue change to a problematic
legacy
and to turn it into something everybody
can celebrate and be proud of and be
happy for
disney said the new concept is quote one
that all of our guests can connect with
and during this national moment of
cultural reassessment this echoes many
other initiatives from leaders across
the entertainment industry
no one's ever done anything like this
for me moving forward
we can all look to a certain disney
princess who might know a thing or two
about working hard to create a better
tomorrow
we don't want little girls to be waiting
for a boy to come
and make themselves complete or to come
to
make their dream happen for them and
hopefully
people in their lives will be able to
assist them and
complete them in some way but the
journey starts with them
you